les propositions communes pour une
coopération monétaire européenne au
cours de la rencontre giscard d'estaing
schmitt une déclaration politique
adoptée par les partis socialistes
européens à bruxelles
assemblée générale du syndicat de la
magistrature et une enquête à béthune
sur ce que l'on appelle les juges rouges
enfin à propos du film promenade au pays
de la vieillesse
georges bigot est allé interroger simone
de beauvoir bonsoir
voilà donc les principaux titres de
notre journal ce soir et je vous propose
tout de suite de commencer par le
mauvais temps
il doit être sans aucun doute l'un de
vos principaux sujets de préoccupation
pendant ce week-end avec notre monsieur
météo que laurent broomhead examinons
ensemble les trois actes de petits
drames premier acte les températures
lent et ben oui c'est pas gai et comme
on le disait jeudi soir de leurs frais
et humide et instable qui vient de
l'atlantique nord a envahi le pays
vendredi et samedi à 14 heures il
faisait 15 degrés à lille et strasbourg
10 degrés au havre 12 degrés à paris 11
à limoges 17 à lyon 14 seulement à
biarritz et le record de chaleur si l'on
peut dire bien il est de 24 degrés à
nice et bastia alors deuxième acte du
drame
le temps pour demain ça continue ça
continue le tour à stable continue et on
peut dire que seul le languedoc et la
provence seront un peu épargné avec un
ciel peu nuageux et du soleil
l'après-midi mais sur le reste de la
france
et bien le temps devrait être assez
semblable à celui d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire avec des éclaircies jamais
très longue qui alterneront avec le
passage de gros nuages qui en se vidant
de l'euro donneront des giboulées des
averses des orages de la grêle est même
un peu de neige au dessus de 2000 mètres
et puis ce qui est particulièrement
irritant il ya du vent surtout fort sur
les côtes de l'ouest alors troisième
acte maintenant les explications du rêve
ou mètres sur 20 sur la sellette
comment peut-on expliquer ce mauvais
temps alors qu'on est quand même
maintenant presque huit jours du début
des vacances et wii puis deux jours
après le début de l'été c'est un petit
peu gênant pas d'habitude en cette
saison est bien le mauvais temps ils
remontent il est plus au dessus des îles
scandinaves et aux cette année depuis
deux semaines et bien on a l'impression
qui s'est installée sur les îles
britanniques et sur le nord de la france
et il faut bien le dire que ça nous
entraîne de l'air qui vient de
l'atlantique qu'il ferait instable et il
est bien difficile de dire quand ça va
s'arrêter et à quel moment
qu'est ce qui va faire que tout d'un
coup l'air chaud qu'on est en droit
d'attendre cette saison va remonter vers
le nord est à nouveau donnée du bout de
temps alors gérard je vous proposer
quelque chose et comme il fait mauvais
demain regarder le ciel tournés vers le
ciel vous verrez ces monstres de la
météorologie
que sont ces gros nuages qui font les
précipitations ça s'appelle des
cumulonimbus la base elle est à 1000
mètres d'altitude
le sommet très tôt une véritable colonne
d'humidité jusqu'à 12000 mètres 12 km là
où il fait si froid que des cristaux de
glace se forme
ces cristaux ou des sandales dans le
nuage il croise au fur à mesure ils
arrivent vers le sol si j'arrive je les
sais de la grêle comme cet après midi
près de paris et puis s'il fonde avant
d'arriver sur les averses
merci monsieur météo autres titres de
l'actualité maintenant la rencontre hier
entre monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
le chancelier schmidt monsieur giscard
d'estaing est rentré satisfait du dîner
de travail qu'il a eue hier soir à
hambourg avec le chancelier schmitt
satisfait parce que dans la préparation
du prochain conseil européen qui doit se
tenir les 6 et 7 juillet à brême le
président français et le chancelier
ouest allemand pourront faire des
propositions communes pour créer une
zone de stabilité monétaire en europe
une europe qui n'a pas le monopole de
l'instabilité monétaire dollar américain
trop faible un yen japonais trop forts
sont aussi des facteurs de déséquilibre
mais il faut bien commencer par le
commencement un accord franco-allemand
sur des projets de solutions à proposer
en convaincu levier les moyens de créer
en europe une zone de stabilité
monétaire
notre conversation et des très
approfondi ou
pour examiner tous les aspects de ce
problème et nous avons réfléchi en
commun aux propositions que nous
pourrions présenter à cet égard les roms
comment remettre de l'ordre dans une
situation monétaire anarchique où les
monnaies varier entre elles sans autre
loi que celle du marché des changes il y
à bien ce qu'on appelle le serpent
monétaire qui fixe des limites à ne pas
dépasser dans les fluctuations des
monnaies mais le franc français
la livre britannique la lire italienne
en sont sortis du serpent une solution
pourrait être d'élargir le serpent
d'autoriser des marges de fluctuation -
et froide pour que france livre élire
puisse y rentrer au besoin avec le
soutien 18 100 marks allemands
en tout cas il semble bien que la
stabilité monétaire on va rechercher à
rétablir lors du prochain conseil
européen de brême soit la condition
préalable à toute véritable relance
économique à laquelle aspirent les pays
du marché comme l'europe encore mais
cette fois avec la conférence des
dirigeants des partis socialistes qui se
sont réunis pendant un jour et demi à
bruxelles but de ce rendez vous
socialiste préparer les élections du
parlement européen au suffrage universel
qui auront lieu au mois de juin de
l'année prochaine
finalement ce n'est pas un programme
électoral qui a été mis au point mais
simplement une déclaration politique
dans laquelle les partis socialistes de
l'europe des neufs précise leurs points
de convergence à partir de cette
déclaration sera lancé un appel solennel
durant le prochain congrès de
l'internationale socialiste en janvier
1979 parti socialiste version française
cette fois avec le débat qui se déroule
depuis quelques jours au sein du ps un
débat qui va être encore évoquée pendant
le week-end au cours d'un colloque
organisé par le crs la gauche du parti
socialiste
un colloque où sera examiné la situation
de la gauche après les élections
législatives et surtout aussi la
situation interne du parti socialiste où
règne il faut bien l'avouer ces temps ci
une certaine effervescence
jean françois kahn minorité majorité
courant sous courants tendance si on ne
suit pas de très près l'actualité il est
fort possible pour un profane de s'y
perdre
alors est ce que pouvait éclairer notre
lanterne
vous savez le parti socialiste a
toujours ressemblé à un fleuve dans
lequel convergent plusieurs rivières ou
pour employer un terme chimiques disons
que c'est une sorte de corps qui est
constitué d'éléments différents et mêmes
quelquefois comme en chimie des éléments
antagonistes alors à l'origine vous
voyez il y avait un corps qui s'appelait
la et ses filles oh là il ses filles ont
été constitués de plusieurs éléments
l'élément guy mollet c'était le chef
l'élément formé par les grandes
fédérations du parti et ses filles au la
fédération du nord la fédération des
bouches du rhône que nous symboliseront
pas mon roi leader de la fédération du
nord est l'élément formé par l'ailé
gauche il ya toujours une aile de gauche
du parti qui symbolisait par chevènement
et vous voyez l'alliance de ces trois
éléments fort mais ce corps qui étaient
là et ses filles oh et puis en 71 un
élément extérieur vient s'introduire
dans ce corps et tout le monde sait en
chimie que lorsqu'un élément extérieur
vient s'introduire dans un coffre a
provoqué des réactions en chaîne
quelle réaction eh bien d'abord
l'élément extérieur vient prendre sa
place et s'allie à deux autres éléments
l'élément chevènement gauche l'élément
grandes fédérations mauroy et expulse un
autre élément
l'élément du mollet donc constitution
d'un nouveau corps monroy chevènement
mitterrand litres en est leader c'est le
parti socialiste d'epinay 75 de nouveau
un élément extérieur vient fait
introduire dans le corps cet élément
extérieur
ce sont d'anciens membres du pays sus
des chrétiens de gauche symbolisée par
monsieur rocard et même processus série
de réactions en chaîne monsieur rocard
vient se joindre à monsieur mauroy qui
représente je le rappelle les grandes
fédérations à monsieur mitterrand cette
fois l'élément guy mollet disparaît et
c'est l'élément chevènement c'est à dire
la gauche du parti qui est rejeté et
voilà si vous voulez le nouveau corps
qui est constituée par le parti
socialiste toujours mitterrand leader
et puis nous avons les élections
présidentielles l'échec la désillusion
et vous savez bien que lorsque en chimie
un corps est confronté un choc imprévus
et bien tous les éléments ont tendance à
attirail et dans tous les sens et c'est
ce qui se passe au fond tout le monde on
dirait vulgairement reprend ses billes
monsieur mitterrand ici naturellement
reste à son poste et est soutenu par ses
amis de toujours ce qu ont toujours été
ses lieutenants symbolisée par le sio et
astier par exemple monsieur rocard lui
qui pense qu'il peut être un successeur
et bien il commence à s'installer son
coin il se prépare et ses amis se
regroupent autour de lui monsieur mon
roi dont je vous ai dit qu'ils
représentent les grandes fédérations du
parti
il sait qu'il va jouer un rôle d'arbitré
alors lui aussi il s'installe à sa place
là quant à monsieur chevènement et bien
lui monsieur chevènement son groupe de
gauche le crs éclate f1 en effet il y en
a qui voudraient soutenir
disons la tendance mitterrand et
d'autres qui voudraient qu'ils
préféraient soutenir la tendance
rocard donc vous voyez que actuellement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
que le corps a éclaté tous les éléments
se sont mis 10 secondes sur des orbites
différents mais le corps nouveau la
majorité nouvelle ne s'est pas encore
constitué voilà dans un langage
chimiques quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui du parti social pour l'album
socialiste vue par jean françois kahn la
politique toujours mais du côté de la
majorité cette fois avec tout d'abord
cette petite phrase de bernard stasi le
porte parole du centre des démocrates
sociaux le rpr et l'udf doivent
coexister dans la majorité le rpr ne
peut plus jouer un rôle dominant
monsieur chirac doit le comprendre et
précisément jacques chirac le président
du rpr juge lui que les gaullistes
appartenant à la majorité n'ont plus
aucune part du pouvoir
les militants du rpr ont le sentiment
d'être traités en adversaire privilégié
du pouvoir la justice maintenant avec
l'assemblée générale aujourd'hui à paris
du syndicat de la magistrature qui a
dressé le bilan de dix années d'activité
cela fait en effet dix ans que ce
syndicat a été créé et selon monsieur
blanchard le secrétaire général du
syndicat de la magistrature
le résultat le plus important est
d'avoir porté sur la place publique les
problèmes concrets de la pratique
judiciaire quotidienne comme par exemple
les accidents du travail les
licenciements et les problèmes de la
consommation assistaient à cette
assemblée générale les membres des
associations professionnelles et
syndicales les représentants du
bâtonnier de paris et les syndicats de
police et parmi les membres du syndicat
de la magistrature
il faut avouer que certains sont sortis
du rang depuis quelques années et en
particulier ils sont sortis du rang pour
avoir remis en cause une certaine idée
de la justice
une section syndicale des magistrats est
en pointe celle de béthune
elle s'est illustré pour avoir par
exemple placer un pdg en prison à cause
d'un accident de travail ou pour entrave
aux droits syndicaux on appelle parfois
ces magistrats les juges rouges
alors françois cornet et jean-louis bout
serre sont allés à béthune pour les
rencontrer je vous appelle des réponses
vous
j'ai 28 ans je suis habitué depuis un
bout et j'exerce âge exerce les
fonctions de substitut
dans ce tribunal je m'appelle maurice
hoarau je suis juge à béthune j'ai 26
ans et je suis là depuis un an et demi
j'ai 26 ans je suis juge à béthune
depuis le 1er février 78 je m'appelle
franck silveira j'ai 29 ans je suis juge
à béthune depuis le 1er février 1977
michel laborde 29 ans juge des enfants
en vue
patrice de s'arrête j'ai 29 ans je suis
juge d'instruction et de thunes depuis
quatre ans on vous appelle le juge rouge
c'est pas du tout d'accord avec une
telle appellation
mon ambition c'est simplement
d'appliquer la loi de la même façon à
tout le monde
dans cette ville de béthune 14
magistrats sur 31 sont âgés de moins de
30 ans et appartiennent au syndicat
national de la magistrature
ils se sont forgés en quelques années
une sévère réputation dans cette ville
est aujourd'hui les relations sont
plutôt tendues entre la justice et les
patrons c'est que les juges rouges comme
on les a surnommés ont bousculé ici
vient des traditions il y a quatre ans à
peine le tribunal de béthune ronronner
paisiblement les bacs de la faire de
bruit s est apaisée
quand débarque un beau matin de mai 74
au palais un jeune juge d'instruction de
25 ans patrice de charrette de la
compris
un an plus tard en septembre 75 cet
élégant jeune homme expédie un pdg en
prison qu'il estime responsable d'un
accident mortel du travail
l'hiver dernier il fait écouter un autre
pdg qui a monté une opération de
commando contraint piquet devrait
changer la justice je dois dire que mon
ambition est beaucoup plus modeste les
avait envoyés jusqu'à présent en deux
pdg en prison pourquoi cet acharnement
contre des patrons à béthune chaque
année 6000 jugements rendus en matière
pénale en trois ans cela fait donc dix
huit mille jugement or on parle
actuellement de deux affaires en
l'espace de trois ans 2 par rapport à 18
milles je pense donc qu'il est tout à
fait excessif de parler d'acharnement ou
d'attitude systématique
est ce que les juges de béthune
appartenance syndicale des magistrats
coeur ne tenons pas à passer dans leur
jugement leur idéologie et leurs idées
je crois que tous les juges lorsqu'il
rendait une décision font toujours
intervenir leur propre vision de la
société ne serait ce que pour des
affaires banales comme des accidents de
la route certains juges considèrent que
le conduite en état d'ivresse et très
grave d'autres que les mois nous ce que
nous prétendons simplement c'est
appliquer la loi à tout le monde ce qui
semble-t-il ne se faisait pas jusqu'à
présent
ce que nous voulons aussi c'est surtout
être contrôlés par les gens au nom
duquel il rend dans la justice c'est à
dire par le peuple français franck
silveira sept autres juges rouges de
béthune dit l'homme tranquille était
l'un des deux assesseurs du tribunal qui
a ordonné l'arrestation de roger le à
l'audience correctionnelle du 1er juin
dernier
un pdg juge à béthune pour entrave au
droit syndical
le second à ses soeurs étaient sept
autres juges de 26 ans jeannie garcia
une décision qui a provoqué un tollé au
palais rebaptisée par les chefs
d'entreprise de la région
le palais de l'injustice ces juges
rouges de béthune sont accusés d'être
organisée en cellules de réflexion
collective de prendre leur décision
comme un avant les jugements qu'ils
rendent ou de recevoir leurs consignes
du syndicat de la magistrature
ils sont accusés également d'être trop
souvent ensemble au palais ou à la ville
comme ici pour ce repas en fait les
autres magistrats comme le barreau leur
reproche surtout de ne pas se fondre
dans le décor est de faire bande à part
la délibération collective
ça nous a été effectivement beaucoup
reproché ça fait partie même des
fantasmes de nos adversaires qui
prétendent que toutes nos décisions sont
prises après une réunion de section
ce qu'on doit dire c'est que c'est
complètement faussé complètement inique
bac
bien entendu on s'offre l'élément
chevènement c'est à dire la gauche du
parti qui est rejeté et voilà si vous
voulez le nouveau corps qui est
constituée par le parti socialiste
toujours mitterrand leader et puis nous
avons les élections présidentielles
l'échec la désillusion et vous savez
bien que lorsque en chimie un corps est
confronté un choc imprévus et bien tous
les éléments ont tendance à attirail et
dans tous les sens et c'est ce qui se
passe au fond tout le monde on dirait
vulgairement reprend ses billes monsieur
mitterrand ici naturellement reste à son
poste et est soutenu par ses amis de
toujours
ce qu'ont toujours été ses lieutenants
symbolisée par uccioi astier par exemple
monsieur rocard lui qui pense qu'il peut
être un successeur et bien il commença à
s'installer sans quoi il se prépare et
ses amis se regroupent autour de lui
monsieur mauroy dont je vous ai dit
qu'ils représentent les grandes
fédérations du parti
il sait qu'il va jouer un rôle d'arbitré
alors lui aussi il s'installe à sa place
là quant à monsieur chevènement vient
lui monsieur chevènement seront son
groupe de gauche le crs éclate
f en effet il y en a qui voudraient
soutenir disons la tendance mitterrand
et d'autres qui voudraient qu'ils
préféraient soutenir la tendance
rocard donc vous voyez que actuellement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
que le corps a éclaté tous les éléments
se sont mis et 10 vont sur des orbites
différents mais le corps nouveau la
majorité nouvelle ne s'est pas encore
constitué voilà dans un langage
chimiques quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui du parti socialiste
pour l'album socialiste vue par jean
françois kahn la politique toujours mais
du côté de la majorité cette fois avec
tout d'abord cette petite phrase de
bernard stasi le porte parole du centre
des démocrates sociaux le rpr et l'udf
doivent coexister dans la majorité le
rpr ne peut plus jouer un rôle dominant
monsieur chirac doit le comprendre et
précisément jacques chirac le président
du rpr juge lui que les gaullistes
appartenant à la majorité n'ont plus
aucune part du pouvoir
les militants du rpr ont le sentiment
d'être traités en adversaire privilégié
du pouvoir la justice maintenant avec
l'assemblée générale aujourd'hui à paris
du syndicat de la magistrature qui a
dressé le bilan de dix années d'activité
cela fait en effet dix ans que ce
syndicat a été créé et selon monsieur
blanchard le secrétaire général du
syndicat de la magistrature
le résultat le plus important est
d'avoir porté sur la place publique les
problèmes concrets de la pratique
judiciaire quotidienne comme par exemple
les accidents du travail les
licenciements et les problèmes de la
consommation assistaient à cette
assemblée générale les membres des
associations professionnelles et
syndicales les représentants du
bâtonnier de paris et les syndicats de
police et parmi les membres du syndicat
de la magistrature
il faut avouer que certains sont sortis
du rang depuis quelques années et en
particulier ils sont sortis du rang pour
avoir remis en cause une certaine idée
de la justice
une section syndicale des magistrats est
en pointe celle de béthune s'est
illustré pour avoir par exemple placer
un pdg en prison à cause d'un accident
de travail ou pour entrave aux droits
syndicaux on appelle parfois ces
magistrats les juges rouges
alors françois cornet et jean louis
blues cr sont allés à béthune pour les
rencontrer
bonjour je m'appelle de référence vous
j'ai 28 ans je suis habitué depuis un an
avant et bien ça exerce les fonctions de
substitut
on s'est tellement je m'appelle maurice
zavaro je suis juge à béthune j'ai 26
ans et je suis là depuis un an et demi
j'ai 26 ans je suis juge à béthune
depuis le 1er février 78 je m'appelle
franck silveira
j'ai 29 ans je suis juge à béthune
depuis le 1er février 1977 2001 d'abord
de 29 ans patrice de charette j'ai 29
ans je suis juge d'instruction de thunes
depuis quatre ans on vous appelle le
juge rouge c'est pas du tout d'accord
avec une telle appellation
mon ambition c'est simplement
d'appliquer la loi de la même façon à
tout le monde
dans cette ville de béthune 14
magistrats sur 31 sont âgés de moins de
30 ans et appartiennent au syndicat
national de la magistrature
ils se sont forgés en quelques années
une sévère réputation dans cette ville
est aujourd'hui les relations sont
plutôt tendues entre la justice et les
patrons c'est que les juges rouges comme
on les a surnommés ont bousculé si bien
des traditions il y a quatre ans à peine
le tribunal de béthune ronronner
paisiblement les bacs de la sphère de
bruay s'étaient apaisées quand débarque
un beau matin de mai 74 au palais un
jeune juge d'instruction de 25 ans
patrice de charrette de la compris
un an plus tard en septembre 75 cet
élégant jeune homme expédie un pdg en
prison qu'il estime responsable d'un
accident mortel du travail
l'hiver dernier il fait écho à un autre
pdg qui a monté une opération de
commando contre un piquet de grève
c'est la justice je dois dire que mon
ambition est beaucoup plus modeste vous
avez envoyé jusqu'à présent en deux pdg
en prison pourquoi cet acharnement
contre des patrons habitude chaque année
6000 jugements rendus en matière pénale
en trois ans cela fait donc dix huit
mille jugement or on parle actuellement
de deux affaires en l'espace de trois
ans 2 par rapport à 18 milles je pense
donc qu'il est tout à fait excessif de
parler d'acharnement ou d'attitude
systématique
est ce que les juges de béthune
appartenance syndicale et magistrature
ne font pas à passer dans leur jugement
leur idéologie et leurs idées je crois
que tous les juges lorsqu'il rendait une
décision font toujours intervenir leur
propre vision de la société ne serait ce
que pour des affaires banales comme des
accidents de la route certains juges
considèrent que le conduite en état
d'ivresse et très grave d'autres que les
mois nous que nous prétendons simplement
c'est appliquer la loi à tout le monde
ce qui semble-t-il ne se faisait pas
jusqu'à présent
ce que nous voulons aussi c'est surtout
être contrôlés par les genres au nom
duquel ils vont dans la justice c'est à
dire par le peuple français franck
silveira sept autres juges rouges de
béthune dit l'homme tranquille était
l'un des deux assesseurs du tribunal qui
a ordonné l'arrestation de roger le à
l'audience correctionnelle du 1er juin
dernier
un pdg juge à béthune pour entrave au
droit syndical
le second à ses soeurs étaient sept
autres juges de 26 ans jeannie garcia
une décision qui a provoqué un tollé au
palais rebaptisée par les chefs
d'entreprise de la région
le palais de l'injustice ces juges
rouges de béthune sont accusés d'être
organisée en cellules de réflexion
collective de prendre leurs décisions en
commun avant les jugements qu'ils
rendent ou de recevoir leurs consignes
du syndicat de la magistrature
ils sont accusés également d'être trop
souvent ensemble au palais ou à la ville
comme ici pour ce repas en fait les
autres magistrats comme le barreau leur
reproche surtout de ne pas se fondre
dans le décor est de faire bande à part